where are you from Jabbar here Compton
Compton yeah born and raised in LA yeah
Wow you were in Compton and then you
went to high school in Compton Oh like
I'm at the door see so it's like South
South LA I write down yeah LaBrie and
Jefferson but what did your parents do
[Laughter]
and now I don't know my dad never ever
better never ever seen him and uh my mom
she was um she's got uh she was on some
drugs and then but now she's a behavior
therapist oh yeah so she made a dope
little comeback she was about that wait
wait growing up she was a drug addict
and mm-hmm and what kind of drugs do you
mind me asking her they crack uh-huh
okay yeah you feel hesitant about
talking about it or no no I'll still
talk about it but like only because um I
think I was like she like made so many
yeah leaps and bounds and yeah so so for
me too so for me to be into like man she
did crack though you know like you can
make a biggest comeback but if you
that's what that's what you're trying to
protect her from cuz once you're like
you know someone's on crack there and
crack forever in their mom's name first
name huh what's your first name I want
to say I want to say I love you she
works as a behavioral therapy okay I
would say if you're listening in your
Jamar's mom whatever your name is I want
to say we because you know I'm a
recovering drug addict myself you know
that Safari or silver yeah and what
everything everything okay so what did
Molly for the first time when maybe like
four days ago would tell me what it is I
know I've heard I just had to say it in
like scripts for me like I wrote in love
they're like it's just they're like you
say Molly and I go what is who she yeah
and they go it's a drug oh yeah yeah so
you didn't Molly so what
nothing I was just about that love wait
are you physical no I was just very like
I was very positive
all right right who are you with myself
but I was talking I was I went to the
itis add a spot at the Comedy Store so I
had to be up there or whatever but so I
guess I was around comics but nobody
really knew I was on it wait how was
your set all right yeah
it'll really enhance my satury but you
go up a late a lot right yeah like what
time level 45 on back yeah but if but
sometimes 10:45 sense they start the
show in the main room like at 8:00 so
it's still late yeah I want to say this
to you though
this is a fact the reason why Jim Carrey
got onto a living color is the fact that
Jim Carrey was a great impressionist but
at one point he said I wanna do weird
[ __ ]
I want to experiment I don't want to do
impressions anymore I would if I want to
do 15 minutes and being a cockroach on
stage he would fully do it on stage you
seen him do this [ __ ] no but I've heard
from other cars that were like hey lend
you know but what mitzi also did was she
used to put the Wayans brothers at the
end right so Jim was always around you
know Damon Wayans and these people up
late and when you're up late no matter
what era was you're the crowds dwindle
mm-hmm and you're with you have a
camaraderie with the comics that are
always late so they would watch each
other and that's when they really fully
grasp how talented Jim Carrey was mm-hmm
Hido so there are also black dudes and
for a white guy to do these broad crazy
things right they're all crossover II
kind of things was just epic for people
and that's how when they got in living
color they go we want this white guy
because we know him but so the
late-night spots you know Sam Kinison
used to get the late spots they're not
bad thing I don't I don't mind him at
all like most people you
you know like a lot of costumes like man
I should be up at 10:45 right or
whatever and I'm like girl [ __ ] man up
like just throw me up so I can do this
[ __ ] yeah you know like I've saved the
like I'll save it like we're all at the
world's best comedy club so that means
we're one of the world's best comics Wow
chill yeah you know I feel like chill
we'll get to whatever timeslot we'll get
to whenever the [ __ ] we get to but I'm
fighting for more than just a [ __ ]
timeslot
why you know at the end of the day so
yeah let me go up there and do my crazy
[ __ ] or what that's a good way to put it
you're fighting for more than just a
timeslot that's a good thing to carry
yeah yeah because you get a little bit
like angry when you don't get a certain
like spot right right I do yeah yeah but
you know I'm leaning toward though I've
done this before where I tell Adam you
get hey serpentina blade yeah so I can
try new [ __ ] yeah it's easier to
experiment at the end mm-hmm do you find
that yeah I mean yeah I mean you know if
you have a packed room that's hot and
you're in between Joey Diaz and
Maniscalco mm-hmm
you don't want to experiment and [ __ ] up
the show so you do you want to crush
mm-hmm but that leaves out
experimentation yeah so you're in a very
lucky situation the problem we gotta get
through go through at the prime spot is
like oh [ __ ] we just have to pack wait
to bring it